[Musique]
ce sont plus de 200 à 1000 visiteurs qui
sont attendus cette année pour la visite
dans ce grand parcours au coeur desquels
se situent à village de fatick les
époques xviiie siècle les artisans
cautionner apporte l'attribution vivante
à ses tableaux historiques et apport
culturel le plus fréquenté de france
après versailles et chambord grand
parcours du puy du fou est devenu de
réputation nationale et c'est le premier
grand parc national même européen pour
sa dimension historique et puis ses
dimensions écologiques pour retenir
l'attention du public il faut chaque
année proposer de nouvelles attractions
nouveauté cette reconstitution d'une
tanière de luz où on leur met en
paillers ce conservatoire d'animaux
sauvages modèle réduit la memorial des
guerres de vendée dramatiser s'il en
était besoin par le requiem de verdi et
un carillon à automates
le grand parcours est tout jeune le
grand parcours n'a que 3 ans et
progressivement il faut l'amener à une
dimension qui soit une dimension
internationale
il faut densifier toutes les attractions
présentes ont tous les jours au public
[Musique]
cette jeune et talentueuse doubleront
des attractions du parc où elle a appris
son métier dans tous les bons coups
[Musique]